[Music]  our team is the elite of the elite the  heart soul of this very big issue  we protect when no one wants to protect  and we go above and beyond there's  nothing you would see me people you're a  frigerator oh that's a very wash you put  me as more than this job and you're  swimming  Victoria leads the new owner a happy  Club duck murder all this started once  we took over I thought we were  lifeguards everything that you guys  talking about sounds like a really  entertaining but far-fetched TV show I  don't feel like running hola you see it  too  Thank You Plan B a great watch Walker  going night-night [ __ ]  grab a hand  you turn the canals into the goddamn X  game yeah that's because we were in  lifeguard pursuit  there's no [ __ ] such famous lifeguard  pursuit even if you were police what you  did would still be totally illegal okay  well I mean it's good thing we're not  police  you